without talking of the looks you
retweeted a photograph not of yourself
last weekend right it was a photograph
of now have you heard of this a hag dude
I've never heard of a hag dude
I don't ever have to know hug dunno oh
so explain what a hug do it is I do well
it's it's the gale May version of a
Hindu right no I think it's where the
hens and stags go together is it see I
don't know what what is it what is it
well to the hags the hags are here so
let's ask them so what is it hi again
stack it's a haystack that's it guys -
yeah we've got the picture that we the
idea the theme of the of the hag do was
you over the years that's plus SIA who
was SIA and it's he's not here
unfortunately
well she right she is on another Church
on the other side of town supposed to be
you in the slow video but he is he he
didn't quite get it right yeah I mean
all you had to do was turn up in a pair
of bathing and there you would think
right so are you married
I am yes so which one which one is for
you I'm Shogo your showgirl Wow okay and
you're marrying Chris and are you in
this no we're nice dykes this weekend
but now see you're having a sad not a
hag nice okay let's give you separate
dude it's very complicated I don't know
what on earth's going on
so you had a hag dude I had a hack do in
Spain and once the demon scene I had
doing a stag do
haggis camper Gracie you're gonna have
Pat do as well as yours completely
different I think mine's more of a stock
dude hey when's it when does actual
credit happening two weeks on Friday I'm
really seeing the dynamic between you
tonight
I'm rolling the dynamic you've chosen
your first dance of you we have and what
is it Cali black oh it's only a song is
it it's love at first light the Abbey
Road slush oh wow fantastic Wow if you
really liked your fan should go into it
live
Gary Barlow would do it that's all I'm
sad
two weeks about oh no busy now have a
lovely day
well done thank you very much the hack
mates with Tom Cruise or Rizzo in love
how you do fall in love with him he's an
amazing event runner yeah very good
we have a restaurant and is this the
restaurant I smell Italian food